36 percent from three during these
playoffs nice Century pass yogic Gordon
with a couple of dunks early on blocking
shots and competing defensively Michael
Malone said at times he was indifferent
about defense earlier in his career nice
entry pads and Murray able to knock it
in
a mile right into jokic finds Hari
Murray wide open
three seconds different shot clock and
game clock Brown Caldwell Polk fires up
a three
rebound seller knocked away Hit the
Floor nice feed and Joker spanks it in
autobio like jokic is a point Center
terrific dish
because here comes the double team spins
away finds Brown wide open Bruce Brown
from downtown
three of 13 from downtown is Miami Jeff
jokic gets inside Zeller Takes a Tumble
and Joker's with a second field goal
already on the drive
again the entry pass an important banks
at home nine assists for jokic
and Gordon's got 14 points these pockets
and windows brought a bio to get good
deep catches he's taken full advantage
tomorrow Murray good luck for three puts
it in
I'm still looking for a mentor from this
crew Murray
up top jokes shot clock winding down
knocks down the three
six on the 24.
hurry trying to find something gets it
to Joker jokic inside to Jeff Green
another beautiful pass from jokic this
13 assists and that stops the 11-0 run
the Joker spinning
backs in out of aisle pokes it away four
to shoot Joker Falling Away puts it in